كلمة رياضي معاق أنا
أكرهها تمامًا ، أنا لا أنظر إلى نفسي على أنني
معاق على الإطلاق لدي إعاقة ،
كل شخص في هذا العالم لديه إعاقة
من نوع ما ولكنك معاق فقط
إذا كنت تعتقد أنك مجرد رياضي
الذي يحتاج إلى أداتين إضافيتين ، أصبحت هذه
القصة الكبيرة ممكنة من قبل
Geico ، نعتقد أن
Geico يمكن أن يوفر لك 15 ٪ أو أكثر من التأمين على السيارات ، وقد
بدأ تاريخي التنافسي الخاص بي
على دراجة BMX عندما كان عمري 13
عامًا والتي تطورت بسرعة إلى
موتوكروس و  دخلت في سباقات
عربات الثلوج في ذروة مسيرتي الاحترافية ،
لقد أنهيت المركز الرابع في
سلسلة البطولات الوطنية ، حيث هبطت على
منصة التتويج عدة مرات في عام 2008
خلال سباق تصفيات في شمال
ميتشغان ، وقد رميت من جهازي
مما تسبب في حدوث مركب.  الكسر الذي
قطع الشريان الرئيسي الذي يغذي
ساقي السفلي ، كان من الواضح بعد ثلاثة
أيام أن البتر كان الطريقة الوحيدة
لإنقاذ حياتي بشكل أساسي ، كنت على الأرض
، أعني أنني لم أرها قادمة على الإطلاق.
الهوى وسبل العيش هو أن أتسابق بعربة ثلجية
أو دراجة ترابية كما
تعلم في البداية ، كما لو
أنني سأنتهي من السباق ، سأنتهي من المنافسة
ولكن بعد حوالي خمسة أسابيع من
حدوث الإصابة ، سأجرب تجربتي الجديدة
ساق صناعية هي المحطة الأولى
التي عملت بشكل جيد للمشي ، لقد كانت حقًا
ساق ميكانيكية أساسية ، لقد ركبت
بالفعل عربة الثلج الخاصة بي في غضون أسبوع أو نحو ذلك من
الحصول عليها ، وفهمت على الفور
أن هذه الساق بالتأكيد
لن تكون تذكرة  لكي أعود
إلى الرياضة التي أحبها ،
لقد واجهت هذه المشكلة بشكل أساسي كنت
بحاجة إلى امتصاص
الصدمات بساقي مثل عضلات الفخذ الرباعية ، هل أعرف
مكونات التعليق من
الدراجات الترابية وعربات الثلوج ، لذلك أنا أنظر إلى
هذا كتعليق  لقد
احتجت إلى صدمة زنبرك وإطارًا
ليحمله جميعًا ويجعله يتحرك في
الاتجاهات التي احتجت إليها للتحرك
ورسمت عليه لمدة خمسة أسابيع تقريبًا أو
حتى مجرد رسومات بالقلم الرصاص وصفحات
وصفحات من التصميمات ثم من هناك  أنا
نحن  nt إلى المتجر وبدأت في تقطيع
الجزء ، كان لدي كل القطع وقمت بتجميعها
ووضعها على ساقي ثم
توجهت على الفور إلى دراجتي الترابية وذهبت في
رحلة بعد سبعة أشهر من الحادث ، كنت
أتسابق على الدراجات الترابية على ساقي
بنيت المرآب الخاص بي
[موسيقى
] تم تطوير الركبة الأصلية للدراجات النارية
من أجل العودة إلى دراجتي الترابية وفي ذلك
الصيف بعد مقابلة مجموعة كاملة من
مبتوري الأطراف الآخرين ، أدركت أن هناك
الكثير من الأشخاص الآخرين الذين يمكنهم
استخدام المعدات التي كنت أعمل عليها
بدأت التفكير في إنشاء
شركة حولها ، أروع جزء في
ما أفعله هو أنه يسمح لي
بالاستمرار في أن أصبح رياضيًا ، لذلك أقوم
بكل الاختبارات على مضمار
السباق ومضمار التدريب الذي يدفعني إلى الكثير
من الأشياء الجديدة  بالإضافة إلى التزلج على الجليد
، اتضح أنني أصبحت جيدًا في ذلك ، لقد
استمتعت أنه تم التحدث عن المنافسة
لأول مرة وتطور ذلك إلى
السفر حول العالم في
جولة كأس العالم وكسب مكاني في بطولة
التزلج على الجليد للمعاقين 2018.  لقد فزت
بميدالية ذهبية وتقاطع حدودي وميدالية فضية
وتعرج بانج ، وأنا حاصل على
الميدالية الذهبية تسع مرات في ألعاب X بين
السباقات التكيفية والدراجات الترابية بدون
عجلات والآن دراجات الثلج ، كما تعلم ، لقد
وصلت إلى أهدافي  مع كل ذلك ،
سأصعد هذا العام
قليلاً وسأحاول التأهل
لسباق الدراجات المحترفة للثلج ، وأخبرك ما الذي
يصعب أن تكون مبتورًا في بعض الأحيان
ولكن هناك العديد من الأشياء المدهشة المختلفة
التي أنا "  كنت قادرًا على التجربة
منذ حدوث إصابتي ، فأنا أستفيد
من الموقف
إلى أقصى حد وما زلت أعيش الحياة على أكمل وجه
[موسيقى]